nous sommes déterminés merci la parole
quand madame arlette grosskost
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances
le plan d'investissement pollock pour
l'europe du plongeon caire doit stimuler
l'économie pour combler l'insuffisance
d'investissements dans l'union
européenne
monsieur john kerr a annoncé que le plan
serait prolongée jusqu'en 2022 et son
volume initialement prévu à 315
milliards d'euros multiplié par deux en
cela confirmée par le conseil écofin qui
a statué hier sur ce sujet pourtant
plusieurs rapports pointent un manque
d'efficacité évident ainsi la cour des
comptes de l'union européenne a jugé que
l'extension du dispositif a été proposé
trop tôt puisque aucune étude n'a été
effectué sur les différents
dysfonctionnements du plan
elle déplore à la fois de possibles
chevauchement avec les autres
instruments financiers européens et un
manque total de transparence le rapport
bruxelles quant à lui critiquent le fait
que les investissements issus du plan
jeunes caire n'apporterait ni bénéfice
net pour l'économie européenne ni valeur
ajoutée je rentre je rappelle que le
total des investissements du dispositif
s'élève aujourd'hui à 116 milliards
d'euros ce qui représente environ 4% de
l'ensemble des investissements réalisés
en un an
cela est largement insuffisant enfin la
commission des affaires européennes du
sénat souligne que les collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas outillés pour
bénéficier avec efficacité des fonds du
plan une égard à la complexité du
montage financier des projets un bémol
pour l'alsace qui s'y est fortement
impliqué au regard de ses nombreuses
critiques
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre nous
informer des retombées réelles et
concrètes du plan france et alors que
les collectivités territoriales sont
financièrement asphyxiée et que le
surcroît elle étouffe sous le poids de
la technocratie gouvernementale que
comptez vous faire pour que nos régions
puissent pleinement s'emparer du
bénéfice du dit plan
question subsidiaire dans le cas de
l'élargissement proposés serez-vous
hamel si le présenter des projets dans
la mini e économie et des finances
merci beaucoup c'est le président
mesdames messieurs les députés
merci madame arlette grosskot pour cette
question parfaitement pertinente et
évidemment plein d'actualité puisque
c'était hier même à l'éco fine à
bruxelles que nous avons pu prendre à ce
nombre de décisions qui me permettront
de répondre de manière très complète à
votre question
le premier ministre disait lui-même il
faut plus d'investissements pour plus de
croissance
et s'il ya une bonne décision qui a été
prise au cours de ces dernières années
par l'europe c'est bien ce que nous
avons l'habitude d'appeler le plan
juncker pour pousser les investissements
en europe dans toute l'europe et dans
chacun des pays tout particulièrement le
nôtre qui ont besoin de ces
investissements investissements publics
de la part de l'état comme des
collectivités locales il faut faire tout
pour simplifier possible l'utilisation
de ces crédits vous avez cité l'alsace
pour vous citer beaucoup d'autres
régions beaucoup d'autres collectivités
qui ont pu utiliser pleinement les plans
juncker où que ce soit bien entendu
disons pas trop bousculés je rappelle
simplement que sur le premier plan
juncker 37 projets en france en sont où
ouais pour plus de pop au prêt de 3
milliards d'euros d'investissement du
plan juncker qui permet de débloquer
près de 12 milliards d'investissements
en france et de considérables et c'est
extrêmement bien vu alors nous avons
décidé hier trois choses la première
c'est de prolonger
vous l'avez dit prolongé de deux ans la
mise en oeuvre de ce plan juncker pour
que chacun puisse y compris quand c'est
un peu compliqué mettre en place des
dispositifs pour utiliser ces crédits
nous avons décidé également vous l'avez
dit vous-même de doubler les crédits en
jeu double et donc on va pouvoir faire
deux fois plus de projets si je voulais
faire un calcul un peu simple peut-être
là où nous avons déjà fait mis en place
30 sujet nous pourrions mettre trente
sept autres encore en france qui viendra
soutenir des investissements
parfaitement utile et puis nous avons
décidé aussi d'élargir les domaines dans
lesquels il est possible d'agir bien sûr
le numérique bien sûr tout ce qui est
environnemental tout ce qui est
énergétique mais aussi parce que c'est
une priorité pour l'europe le domaine de
la défense et